hi and welcome to serverless migration
station a serverless expedition mini
series dedicated to helping developers
modernize their apps to using the latest
features available to one of our
serverless compute platforms today we're
continuing our coverage of migrating
from app engine task queues to cloud
tasks sounds great and i'm so happy to
be here wes
last time in module 7 we added app
engine task queues specifically push
tasks to our sample app engine ndb flask
app so what are we doing today oh that's
right martin for those who haven't seen
the module 7 video or completed its code
lab please pause here to do so because
we pick up from where module 7 leaves
off
today we're migrating from app engine
ndb to cloud neb and app engine task
used to cloud tasks all the links you
need are down below
now wait wes did you say we're migrating
from app engine and the b and app engine
task queues to cloud ndb and cloud tasks
isn't that two migrations
that's right martin while the code will
undergo both migrations we're only
focused on app engine task queues to
cloud tasks because moving from app
engine adb to cloud ndb was already
covered in module 2.
modernizing your apps means moving off
of the legacy app engine services like
ndb and task queues to standalone
services like cloud and eb and cloud
tasks so doing both at the same time
preparing our app to upgrade to python 3
next in module 9. so for all of you the
same drill as earlier with module 7. if
you haven't seen the module 2 video or
completed its code lab we invite you to
pause and do that here so you're
familiar with it as we're going to
concentrate only on task queues here wow
that's a lot of review but i think i'm
caught up now that's great martin now
that you're up to speed let's talk about
what we're doing remember the code for
module 7 where we deleted all visits
older than the oldest displayed from
datastore well we're going to keep that
functionality but moving the code to
cloud tasks
since it's a standalone product there's
a little bit more setup to do
in addition we're also migrating from
app engine nav to cloud any b as
mentioned before
sounds good
i'm going to do this by hand while you
are explaining it so would you please
point me to the code in the codelab
oh for sure martin if you did the module
7 codelab please start with your own
code base but if you didn't clone the
repo or download the zip file we're
going to start with the module 7 code
and finish with what's in the module 8
folder here's the codelab as well so
pause one more time to get everything
you need once you're ready let's go to
the computer and migrate it now
if you don't have a confirmed working
module 7 app yet upload to app engine
with gcloud app deploy
most users watching this video will be
on python 2 so if that's the case ensure
your lib folder is ready to go if not or
you're unsure delete what you have and
run pip install so that you have it
confirm the apps the same as from module
7 whether it's your own or ours once you
have then you're ready to
go changes to the config files are
nearly identical to the changes made in
module 2. we're adding use of the google
cloud client libraries and these changes
include adding required built-in
packages that go into app.yaml instead
of requirements.txt
now anytime built-in libraries are used
a few more lines of code have to be
added to app engine config to point your
app to them so make these changes as
well
now let's do the non-built-in libraries
like cloud nab
in module 2 we added cloud ndb to
requirements.txt
this time we're also going to add the
cloud tasks library
python 2 users should now delete their
lib folder and run the pip install
command to install flask cloud ndb and
cloud tasks to the lib folder
again these updates are just like in
model 2 but adding both cloud ndb and
cloud tasks
now let's move to main.py
at the top swap out the imports of app
engines task queue and ndb libraries and
replacing them with the google cloud
equivalents
the payload sent to cloud tasks needs to
be json encoded so we're going to have
to use that standard library module as
well
next most cloud libraries require a
client for each service you're using in
our case cloud nab and cloud tasks
more specifically cloud tasks requires a
project id and an apps region along with
the queue name now this wasn't required
with app engine task queues but
recognize that cloud tasks and now a
separate product that can work with both
app engine and not app engine apps hence
the extra red tape
fortunately its client provides a
convenience function named q path that
builds a fully qualified path string for
us
be sure to swap in your app's values
into the placeholder constants
now creating a new visit and querying
the most recent visits doesn't really
change the only difference is due to
cloud nab requiring use of its python
context manager when making data store
calls so you'll see a new with block
containing such calls in both store
visit and fetch visits
review the module 2 codelab in video if
you need more information here
for us in module 7 things get really
interesting from here on out meaning
that once we grab the timestamp of the
oldest visit displayed we can move on
with the app engine task you library
it's a single call to create a push task
and respond back to the user
with cloud tasks it's also a single call
however there's a little bit more setup
after logging the oldest timestamp you
see the necessary payload that cloudtask
needs a flag indicating an app engine
request
a handler uri json encoded parameters
and an http header pass this data plus
the task queue path from the above to
create task
that's it and the return doesn't change
as far as the task handler goes not much
change here either yes pulling out the
parameter in a slightly different any
data store code is within a with block
but querying logging and deletion of old
entities is pretty much the same
there are very few changes here because
it's mostly still the same http post
method we had in module 7.
cloud tasks is just an alternative
execution platform you really shouldn't
need to change anything in the handler
finally there are no changes to the main
application handler route
ensure you've made all the updates we
just covered to your sample app after
uploading with gcloud app deploy it
should run exactly the same as before
except now it uses cloud tasks
if you're using no other legacy app
engine services it is now safe to port
your app to python 3. congratulations
cool thanks for showing us that wes i'm
surprised how similar cloud tasks is to
app engine push tasks
is there a guide to help me get a better
grasp of migrating app engine push
queues to cloud tasks oh definitely
below you're going to find a link to the
specific migration guide for moving push
queues to cloud tasks
okay and while you're at it can you also
point me to the docs for the original
app engine task queues as well as cloud
tasks
rest assured my friend links to both of
those are also down below
sounds good
usually about this time i ask you what
other migrations we should look at
but that's not the case today is it no
martin it's not the next step is for you
to stay tuned for module 9 where we're
going to port this module 8 app that we
just finished looking at to python 3
including an optional migration to cloud
firestore and we look forward to having
you join us on that excursion this is
wesley on behalf of martin and porter
and we'll see you at that next migration
station or on another serverless
expedition soon in the meantime happy
travels
[Music]
you